I don't think we can do enough videos on
why raising something to a negative
exponent is equivalent to 1 over that
base raised to the positive raised over
the positive exposed to the positive
exponent I should say and to get more
intuition about why this makes sense I
look at different powers of two and then
think about what makes sense as we go to
exponents below zero integer exponents
below zero so let's start let's start
with two to the third power well two to
the third power is two times two times
two which of course is equal to eight
now what about two to the second power
well that's going to be two times two
which is of course equal to four and to
go from two to the third to two to the
second power what happened here where we
divided by 2 we divided by two
now let's keep going what about two to
the first power well that's just two and
once again to go from two squared and
two to the first power we divided by we
divided by two now things are going to
get interesting two to the 0th power and
actually this will help build the
intuition of why it's something to the
something non zero to the zeroth power
is defined to be 1 well so far every
time we decremented the exponent by one
we essentially divided by two so we
should divide by two again so if we
divide by two again we get one and this
is part of the motivation why 2 to the
zero power should be equal to one but
let's keep going
what should 2 to the negative 1 power be
if we want to be consistent about
continuing to / - well we divide by two
again we divide by two again and so this
is going to be equal to 1/2 notice 2 to
the negative 1 is 1/2 2 to the 1 is
equal to 1 this is equal to the
reciprocal of this let's keep going this
is this is fun so what should 2 to the
negative 2 power be well we should
divide by 2 again divided by 2 again you
get to 1/4 I think you see the pattern
- to the negative 3 power well we should
divide by 2 again and we get to 1 over 8
which is the reciprocal of 2 to the
third power so once again another way to
think about why negative exponents are
about taking reciprocals to take taking
something the negative exponent is
equivalent to 1 over taking that same
base to the positive exponent